qu'est ce que vous faites cooper comment
vous avez un côté sanguin dans mon
rapport sais je vous assure c'est
cerveau que j'ai voulu écrire j'ai
parcouru votre dossier vous avez eu de
très bons résultats à l'académie
informatique soutien au personnel sans
surprise jusque là mais vous fait montre
d'une certaine réserve au bureau qui
pourrait laisser penser que vous n'avez
jamais ne serait-ce qu étaient armés
alors imaginez ma surprise à la vue de
ces images filmées à l'académie
justement c'est aussi parce que c'est
vraiment moi j'ai du mal s'est propulsé
film en accéléré avec l'ampleur de la
tâche
ontex tgv regardez cette vidéo - cast
fond des filets tellement je mettais
tout ça sur youtube